Would you say that again?
The sun?
There are over 7,000 languages spoken in the world...
...and unfortunately, at least half of those languages are in danger of extinction.
Scientists estimate that a human language disappears about every two weeks.
And in Australia there are at least a hundred languages...
...that are hanging on the very brink of extinction.
You might wonder why we should care if an obscure Australian language...
...that only has three speakers goes extinct.
Why does that affect us?
The knowledge that those people possess is unique.
They've been here long before humans populated Europe.
They have intricate knowledge of plants and animals...
...that may not even be known to science at all.
Most of this knowledge has never been written down anywhere.
You can't find it in a book or in an encyclopedia or a database.
It's only in people's heads.
If that knowledge evaporates, then we've all lost something.
We're all impoverished by the death of a single language.
As a linguist and as a scientist, I feel a real sense of urgency.
People travel around the world to see things that they think are ancient.
The ancient in Australia is not in the seeing, it's not buildings or monuments.
It's in the hearing: to hear the wisdom...
...from the mouths of the last speakers of these nearly extinct languages.
The transmission of knowledge has been disrupted.